payant de ferrero comme les cours d'été
nous
m
[Musique]
vous nous avez fait toute une frousse
l'été dernier vous avez eu un malaise
oui récemment vous avez été opéré en
faisant installer finalement un
stimulateur cardiaque c'est ça alors je
me permets de la question suivante
comment va la santé bon ça va j'ai été
opéré à maisonneuve rosemont
arch arriver là et on m'a dit allez vous
coucher tout tu es dans le lit que vous
voyez là matt henjak est et dans la
prévision m'a poussé mon père
parce que j'ai je pense est proche la
fin comme on dit erbacci proches comme
du commerce à deux lancers ce qui
m'ennuie ray c'est d'écouter mes amis
j'ai des bons moments
[Musique]
je
la paix
j'ai eu une carrière que j'ai aimé je
chante je trouve en gardant le chanteur
mais j'aime ça et puis j'ai fait
beaucoup de riz qui vaut beaucoup de
plaisir citer qu'un magouët état de
santé est plein d'humour mais d'où
vient-il ce rire la demande et michel de
dodo mais mon père
beaucoup de mots et michel forget et
comme mon grand frère que j'aime
beaucoup a vécu chez nous et est papa
disait que tu maintiens une chose michel
je sais pas me voir je pense qu'ils vont
faire une carrière
l'idée roland barthes ores et déjà de
paris lui aussi est allé avec mon père
et mon père c'est un homme de voix un
homme bon un homme tu es vraiment un kit
peut avoir confiance à 100%
né à bastia je suis comédienne
adévia la donation je suis né après la
pole est ma troisième aviation celle ci
est mon dernier bail vert vous êtes la
reine du bye bye aux non tu vois là tu
parles laragne les bye bye j'ai eu
beaucoup de plaisir on n a offert le bye
bye pour lyon va faire ses fonctions
offertes selon mme sow on se pose on
essayait de se faisait de ce faire et on
se faisait lui aussi comme quand j'avais
fait ma thèse appui que patrice donné
des coups de recherche sur l'être est
totalement fou ça va bien avec mère
theresa may c'était de rouge
si l'on fait le week-end sur radio
canada pardon mais jusqu'où lit on à mon
sens de cette drôlerie delà c'est pile
et on écrivait puis s'est amusé à dire
tiahrt son moi je les ai vus imiter
michael jackson bye bye
oui tout un défi à se limitent les oui
ben oui j'avais pris est pas là mais
seuls de s'habiller ou saviez où tu est
maintenant tu la poche parce que tu
paries partir pendant l'arrière et tout
ça on l'a où on l'a pas mais moi j'ai
dit que j'avais pas au départ laquelle
vous n'avez correct chute
j'avais saisi comment c'était et c'est
très bien de faire ça parce qu'on se dit
je lui laisse pendant huit tours mais
c'est sûr qu'on est moins perfectionnées
et moins - danseurs que lui l'était mais
c'est toujours un grand plaisir que bmc
l'occident va comme ça à nizon l'année
de votre premier bye bye 1971 c'était
aux séries de votre premier film que
j'ai revu tout récemment c'est toi bien
après y'a papa ça va donner un grand
prix avec qui vont des avec yvon
deschamps
un film très politique très féminine oui
vous avez un personnage de femme forte
principe et absolument tout la bleue le
nid familial
ouais et que la difficulté que ses
relations avec les hommes avec les oui
exactement
ce face à face à l'époque ouais et
d'ahmed ma propre vie j'avais de la
difficulté
peut-être parce que j'étais à la
télévision et les grottes et pas habitué
à voir à sortir avec quelqu'un que le
monde connaissait mais c'est un
personnage là qu'ils voyaient à
télévision dans ce que l'oignon dans la
vis des non pas que la le manque
d'argent passent à côté de moi pin sec
bonjour c'est quand allez vous alors
c'est sûr peut-être mais ça me
dérangeait pas pour dire pour être bien
franche mais c'était c'était des grands
moments
- là si j'avais su je peux travailler
j'ai eu du plaisir
jiri je me suis moqué et jamais ça parce
que se moquer de quelqu'un et que les
gens rient siphonne alors je non j'étais
très heureuse
j'étais très heureuse dans mon métier et
je suis contente d'avoir façon parce que
j'ai eu du plaisir demander qu'une chose
offshore comprise et remercie infiniment
des beaux souvenirs
[Musique]